welcome to this video playing a five
minute game here on the ICC the reuleaux
pass I'm trying out a new line IAM the
deferred Steinitz variation it's um
somewhat forgotten line but not a bad
one might have six year I cannot really
remember why is a g6 okay let's start
with that yeah one idea of this line is
that black sometimes really manages to
play an a quick g6 not here really but
in another variation that happens
frequently maybe night h5 here okay
interesting okay yeah take the bishops
no no hesitation down okay hmm yeah
maybe d4 d5 will lead us to a very close
position you try to avoid that
yeah now it won't be totally closed y
term will probably play d5 so now I'm I
will play c62 to get the position opened
up
interesting moment here I could I can
even take on d5 or play c5 which you did
would close the position again but not
not a bad moment actually for a c5 yeah
maybe maybe not why not I it looks like
a decent positions
yeah yeah and this is one of the move
that I thought about but I thought that
just g6 would be very fine i'm covering
h8 so g5 i can take and that's not
really leading to anything and then the
long run this d4 pawn can be a liability
for instance after something like how do
i actually get down Bishop g7 night g8
f6 attacking g4 mum or get the night une
25 even yih seven came this is useful
anyway on f6 it's not doing anything
yeah it takes takes I can take on the
Akeley can take on a eight but that's
not not nothin wyd anything it's in fact
quite typical that the loss of the dark
squared bishop is a big problem in this
structure it's just leading to many dark
squared weaknesses like a four and so on
yeah just Knight f6 as intended on yeah
probably so this night retreated yeah
here there is there is h5 as a
possibility the night takes yeah let's
do that getting rid of the double palm
but still I'm activating all this I
didn't you consider
night h7 distance is just winning the
pawn now there is g4 but I don't think
that this is any good hmm it's a bit
weird
yeah this was pretty much clear at least
them getting the Queen to it to a worse
square now I'm going to attack the spawn
don't see how it keeps it yeah maybe you
can try to get quick counter play on the
queenside but it looks tricky this was
pretty much bound to happen after white
had played this g5 advance the porn is
just weak I only am expected the capture
on age 5
yeah I know it's tricky but if what is
always stepping the time it won't help
okay so I'm taking this why should i
cancel first I can't take this keep it
simple okay maybe just open taking now
on f3 Janice has the big advantage that
my that my queen is actually free to
move now yeah the rook on the a file of
course I would like to get it traded
they probably come to a 70 so maybe this
is an idea covering a seven covering d6
and possibly castles queen bee 7 rugae
it coming yeah if I just take it and
then play King to e7 covering f6 you
know this looks nice really yeah I
thought I can I can take on the edge for
now rook age five and two queen 2 h8 you
can go ok seven but this is just one
piece it doesn't scare me so much now
maybe really here yeah let's do that
yeah nidus it ticked oh okay because
it's a pin it's a pin of course hmm time
warning yeah maybe slightly slightly
ugly maybe I can play a 5 here f5 takes
takes Queen takes a through each one
with made ok I also have more time than
then why does but where this is a mate
check Queen extra checkmate checkmate
yeah this I had seen hmm yeah the really
g5 is just as just a satirical arrow and
he must take that that's the only move
and this was also why I played it i
thought well the capture this this and
really thought about but after the
capture i get this night possibly
activated here and it looks like a
decent position yeah the problem is
simply that this pawn is going to drop I
mean no way he keeps it here there also
was this idea and then capturing on g5
maybe in an option as the queen is
nicely covering the a file but I don't
think I did anything particularly wrong
yeah here the immediate fight was even
stronger much stronger actually yeah now
if you look at it hmm yeah where's the
nut actually going it needs to go here
program his check yeah that search is
very bad for what that's even more
convincing than than the game I had
Addison this year I was slightly
uncomfortable so all of a sudden as
white is probably threatening to take on
d7 crushing through him so and five and
okay this wasn't any good this wasn't
any good at all because of take stakes
and now 93 hmm yeah I didn't really
appreciate that fi the singing know it
it runs like that and why this what's
better hmm against a tease out the mayor
so somewhat shaky a realization of my
advantage okay thanks for watching